Les armes de la dernière chance
L'histoire de l'aviation connaît
une étape importante en juillet 44.
Cette année-là, le Mosquito de la RAF
était l'un des rares avions alliés
à pouvoir pénétrer facilement
l'espace aérien allemand.
Il fut abattu par un Messerschmitt 262
piloté par le lieutenant Alfred Schreiber.
Il eu l'honneur de la première victoire
aérienne remportée à bord d'un jet.
Si le Messerschmitt 262 était
à la pointe de la technologie en 1944,
il était l'aboutissement
du long intérêt allemand
pour la propulsion à réaction.
Ainsi, l'Allemagne fit voler
le premier avion à réaction de l'histoire,
le Heinkel 178, le 24 août 1939.
Il avait un réacteur de seulement
500 kilos de poussée.
En soit, le 178 n'était rien d'autre
qu'une innovation technique
sans potentiel militaire.
Pour Wankel, il démontrait pourtant
qu'on pouvait développer
des avions à réaction pour le combat.
Il avait déjà entamé les études
pour un chasseur biréacteur
avec des moteurs bien plus puissants.
Il en résulta le Heinkel 280.
Lors de son premier vol,
le 2 avril 1941,
il était sans doute le plus avancé
des avions au monde.
Avec deux réacteurs développant chacun
plus de 700 kilos de poussée,
le Heinkel 280 réussit à atteindre
la vitesse maximum de 770 km/h.
Des réacteurs améliorés
auraient permis d'espérer
une vitesse de 900 km/h.
Au printemps 1942, les essais
de plusieurs prototypes avaient,
pour Heinkel,
validé le concept du 280.
Cependant, son sort fut scellé
par ses moteurs.
Ses réacteurs, aussi conçus par Heinkel,
n'ont jamais réussi à atteindre
la puissance désirée.
Les échanger avec les Jumo Junkers
revenait à adopter
les mêmes réacteurs que le 262.
Ce dernier, qui n'avait pas encore volé,
fut préféré par la Luftwaffe,
car ll semblait disposer
d'un potentiel plus important,
et le 27 mars 1943,
Heinkel fut invité à abandonner le 280.
On accuse le pouvoir politique allemand
de n'avoir su déceler le potentiel
de ces avions à réaction
et leur impact positif sur la Luftwaffe,
mais n'oublions pas que pendant
les deux premières années du conflit,
on espérait une guerre courte.
En conséquence, Ernst Udet, ici à gauche,
qui supervisait les projets
de la Luftwaffe,
et Hans Jeschonnek, le chef d'état-major
de l'aviation,
étaient peu enthousiastes pour ces avions.
C'est pourquoi leur potentiel
ne fut pas reconnu avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
et que le temps perdu
le soit irrémédiablement.
Alors même que Messerschmitt
expérimentait le turboréacteur,
une technique encore plus radicale
de propulsion était en développement
avec l'installation d'une fusée Walter
dans un fuselage
conçu par le Dr Walter Lippisch
de l'Institut allemand de recherche
sur les planeurs.
Messerschmitt fit voler le prototype
du Messerschmitt 163 au printemps 1941.
C'était une évolution
du planeur d'origine,
mais il n'était pas encore au niveau
de Messerschmitt 163 B de production.
Les essais en vol continuèrent
au centre expérimental de Peenemünde.
Les essais en vol montrèrent
de remarquables performances,
y compris un taux de montée phénoménal
avec sa vitesse de 900 km/h.
À cette occasion,
il fut remorqué à 13 000 pieds.
Une fois largué, il alluma sa fusée
et atteint la vitesse de 1000 km/h.
Une fois le carburant consommé,
l'avion revient
à son état d'origine de planeur.
Les versions de série partageaient
avec le prototype
une vitesse d'atterrissage très élevée.
La version de série, le prototype B,
était une évolution logique du A.
Cependant, la fusée Walter problématique
restait au cœur du concept.
Développant une poussée maximum
de 1700 kilos,
son principal danger était
la nature de son carburant.
Le carburant de la fusée comprenait
80 pour cent de peroxyde d'hydrogène
et de l'oxyquinoline ou du phosphate,
communément appelé T-Stoff,
et une solution aqueuse
de permanganate de calcium,
dénommée C-Stoff.
Ce mélange très instable pouvait exploser
dans certaines circonstances.
Le pilote et les équipes au sol
devaient porter des vêtements spéciaux
pour se protéger contre la nature
hautement corrosive du liquide
capable de dissoudre la peau humaine.
Lors des essais au sol,
le moteur était souvent refroidi
par liquide.
Les essais du Messerschmitt 163 B
commencèrent en 1943,
mais les premiers avions de série
furent livrés à la Luftwaffe
en mai 1944 seulement.
Les usines étaient dispersées
dans toute l'Allemagne.
Le site d'assemblage final était
secrètement installé dans la Forêt Noire
et desservi par une voie ferrée.
La production était donc problématique.
La première unité ne devint opérationnelle
sur 163 qu'en juillet 44.
La JG 400, basée à Brandis,
arborait son insigne distinctif
sur le nez de ses avions,
une puce équipée d'une fusée.
Engagé au combat dès le 28 juillet,
ce n'est que le 24 août
que le Feldwebel Schubert, ici à l'image,
revendiqua la première victoire.
La disponibilité du 163 B
n'a jamais été très bonne et dès juillet,
les difficultés ont commencé surtout
pour la livraison du carburant
à partir des raffineries
de Ludwigshafen et de Leverkusen.
Non seulement ces sites étaient la cible
des bombardiers US,
mais le T-Stoff et le C-Stoff
étaient aussi utilisés
par le module de lancement
des bombes volantes V1
qui entrait tout juste en service.
Les stocks de ce carburant étaient
alloués aux V1 plutôt qu'à la JG 400.
Celle-ci n'avait que
huit Messerschmitt 163 en ligne de vol,
le 24 août, lorsqu'une force de 185 B-17
s'approcha de l'usine de fabrication
de carburant synthétique de Merseburg.
Les 163 furent mis en alerte.
Ils grimpèrent rapidement à l'altitude
et vers l'arrière de la formation
de bombardier.
Les 163 s'approchèrent ensuite
et ouvrirent le feu
avec leur canon de 30 mm.
La vitesse des 163 ne leur permettait
qu'une très courte passe de tir.
Schubert réussit
à descendre deux B-17.
À épuisement du carburant,
le 163 revient rapidement
vers son terrain en vol plané.
L'approche et l'atterrissage
étaient effectués à très grande vitesse.
Le petit ski escamotable sous le ventre
de l'appareil n'était pas très efficace.
De nombreux pilotes
furent blessés voire tués
dans les dernières secondes
de leur mission.
Le Messerschmitt 263 se proposait
d'améliorer ce point
avec un train d'atterrissage
plus conventionnel,
mais ne put entrer en service
avant la fin de la guerre.
En raison du danger constitué par le 163,
il était vital de récupérer chaque avion
très rapidement après l'atterrissage.
On conçu un chariot spécial
pour cette fonction.
Il disposait d'un vérin hydraulique
pour soulever le 163
afin qu'on puisse le remorquer.
L'avion était soulevé suffisamment haut
pour permettre aux mécaniciens
de replacer le chariot de décollage
et ainsi le "Komet",
tel qu'il était officiellement appelé,
était prêt pour une nouvelle mission.
On attendait beaucoup du 163,
spécialement après ce qu'il avait démontré
le 24 août,
mais ces espoirs furent déçus.
Les quatre B-17 descendus le jour
de sa première victoire aérienne
furent ses seuls succès.
En septembre,
après les raids américains
contre les raffineries produisant
les T et C-Stoff,
le carburant produit après fut alloué
exclusivement au V1
et les 163 de la JG 400 se retrouvèrent
délaissés et cloués au sol,
privés du carburant qui
leur aurait permis de prendre l'air.
Le 163 a bien été le concept
d'avion de chasse le plus extrême
à être entré en service pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Acclamé par beaucoup
en Allemagne et au-delà
comme le plus formidable avion de combat
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
le Messerschmitt 262 représentait
un grand espoir pour la Luftwaffe.
La première cellule de 262
a volé dès 1941,
mais avec un moteur à pistons.
Il fallut attendre le mois de mars 1942
pour que le premier prototype puisse voler
avec ses réacteurs BMW
et un moteur à pistons.
Le prototype V3 devient le premier
à disposer d'une autre motorisation,
les réacteurs Jumo,
bien plus puissants.
Afin de disposer
d'une indispensable piste en dur,
le 262 fut transféré à Leipheim
pour les tests et le 18 juillet 1942,
il vola pour la première fois
avec ses seuls réacteurs.
Le V3 commence son roulage.
Aux commandes, Fritz Wendel,
pilote d'essai de Messerschmitt.
Inquiet de savoir
comment la queue de son appareil
pouvait prendre la ligne de vol,
Wendel se servit des freins
avec précaution
pour forcer l'arrière
du fuselage à se soulever.
Quelques secondes plus tard,
le 262 était en vol.
À l'atterrissage, l'avion s'est retrouvé
entouré de fumée
plus spectaculaire que dangereuse.
Quelques petits problèmes
s'étaient révélés,
mais le 262 était globalement
satisfaisant.
Les mois qui suivirent permirent
de modifier l'aile
pour lui donner
sa flèche constante caractéristique.
Motivé par le rapport enthousiaste
d'un de ses pilotes,
Adolf Galland pilota le quatrième
prototype en mars 1943.
Sa réaction fut plus qu'enthousiaste :
"C'était comme être poussé par un ange."
En conséquence, il recommanda que tous
les projets de chasseurs en cours
soient annulés pour se concentrer sur
les Focke-Wulf 190 et Messerschmitt 262.
Mais les désirs de Galland ne pouvaient
être satisfaits si facilement.
En novembre, à la suite
d'une démonstration,
Hitler ordonna que non seulement
on donne toute la priorité à cet appareil,
mais qu'il fallait en faire un bombardier,
pas un chasseur.
Göering lui assura
qu'il pouvait bien être équipé de bombes.
Il demanda
également que l'avion soit prêt
pour contrer le probable
débarquement allié en Europe.
Messerschmitt ne réussit pas
à surmonter les difficultés techniques
du fuselage et des moteurs
suffisamment vite
pour que le 262 entre en production,
comme chasseur
ou comme bombardier avant juin 1944.
Les avions qui quittèrent
les usines en juillet,
entrèrent en service avec le KG 51,
surnommé le "Kommando Schenck".
Ils entrèrent en action
sur le nord de la France en août 1944.
La version de bombardement
était surnommée "Storm Bird"
pour la distinguer de la version
de chasse baptisée "Hirondelle".
Deux bombes de 250 kilos
ou une seule bombe de 500 kilos
pouvaient être installées
sous le fuselage,
tout en conservant l'armement de quatre
canons de 30 mm dans le nez.
En dépit de l'insistance d'Hitler
et du lobbying d'autres responsables
exigeant que l'avion soit produit
comme un bombardier éclair,
la plupart des responsables
de la Luftwaffe,
un peu concerné par le problème,
voulaient plutôt la version de chasse.
Les premières livraisons du chasseur
précédèrent les versions de bombardement
avec le détachement expérimental
du commandant Thierfelder,
qui avait effectué ses premières
missions opérationnelles en avril 1944.
À sa mort, le commandement
de l'unité fut confié par Galland
au major Walter Nowotny,
l'as du front est.
C'est un 262 du Kommando Nowotny
qui fut utilisé pour réaliser
ce film d'instruction
pour les pilotes en formation sur le jet.
Ceci était vraiment indispensable,
car le pilotage du 262
était bien plus exigeant
que celui des avions
à moteur à pistons.
Sa supériorité technologique le rendait
peu évident d'emblée à ses pilotes.
Bien qu'étant un avion très rapide,
son accélération était assez lente
en raison de la conception
de ses réacteurs Jumo.
Les commandes de gaz devaient
être utilisées lentement,
sinon le compresseur pouvait décrocher
et s'éteindre ou être détruit.
Une fois en l'air,
le pilote ne pouvait utiliser le 262
comme un 109 ou 190,
juste plus rapide.
Le combat tournoyant
était impossible avec le 262
en raison de son rayon
de virage très important.
Cela signifie
qu'un Mustang, un Thunderbolt,
un Spitfire ou un Tempest
pouvait tourner bien plus court.
Mais les attaques en piqué pour prendre
de la vitesse permettaient aux 262
de passer facilement le rideau défensif
des chasseurs ennemis
et de frapper directement
les bombardiers américains
avec ses puissants canons de nez.
On a déjà mentionné les problèmes
rencontrés par Junker et Messerschmitt
avec les moteurs Jumo,
mais il faut remonter
un peu dans le temps
pour mieux comprendre les problèmes
affrontés par ces deux compagnies
dans leur tentative de mise en service
du Messerschmitt 262
en quantité significative.
L'importance du Messerschmitt 262
pour le futur de la Luftwaffe
a été reconnue dès le 2 juin 1943,
avec l'autorisation du lancement
du nouvel appareil comme chasseur.
Mais cette décision fut confrontée
aux problèmes techniques
rencontrés sur cet avion et ses moteurs.
On peut mesurer l'importance
de ces problèmes
en notant que six mois
après cette décision,
seulement 23 cellules de Messerschmitt 262
avaient été construites
et qu'aucune n'avait jamais volé
en raison du manque de moteurs.
Junker avait aussi
d'importantes difficultés à surmonter
et devait faire face à la fois
à ses problèmes techniques,
mais aussi à la pression de ceux
qui avaient besoin de ces moteurs
pour commencer à produire en quantité
non seulement le Messerschmitt 262,
mais aussi le bombardier Arado 234.
Au centre des soucis de Junker
avec son réacteur,
il y avait les problèmes liés
à la situation déclinante
de l'Allemagne en guerre
et face à laquelle
la compagnie était impuissante.
Le Jumo 004 était, à cette époque,
le plus avancé
de tous les réacteurs existants alors.
Véritable chef d'œuvre, il exigeait
une construction de grande qualité
avec des matériaux spéciaux et rares,
capables de supporter
les énormes contraintes thermiques
produites par un réacteur.
Le nickel et le chrome,
qui n'étaient plus disponibles
en Allemagne en 1944, en faisaient partie.
À leur place, Junker devait utiliser
des métaux moins adaptés
ou utiliser les matériaux stratégiques
encore en stock,
en faible quantité et avec parcimonie.
Par exemple,
dans des circonstances normales,
la chambre de combustion
aurait dû être construite en aluminium.
Mais avec la pénurie de ce métal,
Junker fut obligé
de la concevoir en acier
recouvert d'une fine couche d'alu
à l'intérieur
pour lui permettre
d'en supporter la chaleur.
En conséquence, les réacteurs 004
n'avaient une durée de vie
que d'environ 10 heures.
Le compresseur avait également
une tendance à décrocher très rapidement.
L'alimentation en carburant
des deux moteurs était délicate à régler.
Si l'essence arrivait trop rapidement
dans la turbine, le réacteur s'étouffait.
Ces nombreux problèmes étaient
au cœur des soucis de la Luftwaffe,
incapable de déployer
le 262 en quantité suffisante.
L'insistance d'Hitler à employer
cet avion comme bombardier
et non pas comme chasseur,
est considérée
comme ayant eu une incidence
sur ses problèmes,
mais sans en être la cause.
Alors que l'ingéniosité allemande
avait permis l'émergence
d'un avion particulièrement performant,
l'industrie militaire était incapable
de surmonter les problèmes
liés à sa propulsion,
ce qui était pourtant
un préalable indispensable
à son déploiement
en quantité suffisante
pour assurer le succès de la guerre
aérienne au-dessus de l'Allemagne.
Alors que la situation militaire
se détériorait encore plus
et que la puissance
des bombardements alliés augmentait,
sous la pression d'Hitler,
voulant disposer rapidement
de son bombardier rapide,
il fut décidé en juin 44
de renoncer à toute amélioration
majeure du Jumo.
En gelant ainsi le design du moteur
avec tous ses défauts,
on put lancer la production.
Cette décision permit de voir
les premières livraisons à la Luftwaffe
avec 28 Messerschmitt 262 A
reçus en juin, 59 en juillet,
seulement 20 en août,
91 en septembre et 117 en octobre.
Au total, la Luftwaffe en avait reçu 315
au début du mois de novembre.
Mais pratiquement tous
les 262 construits alors étaient prévus
pour être des chasseurs bombardiers.
Hitler ne voulait pas changer d'avis.
Dans le mois
qui a suivi sa nomination,
le nouveau chef d'état
major de la Luftwaffe
pressa Hitler de permettre
au 262 de devenir un chasseur pur.
La seule concession du Führer
fut d'autoriser
la construction d'un chasseur
tous les 20 appareils produits.
Ceci était inacceptable
pour le général Kreipe
et ce fut la cause
de sa démission en septembre.
Ce ne fut qu'en novembre que Hitler,
finalement recula et donna l'autorisation
de lancer la production des 262 de chasse,
mais dans son obstination,
il insista pour
que chaque avion soit capable
d'emporter au moins
une bombe de 250 kilos.
La situation à ce moment-là
était si mauvaise pour la Luftwaffe
que Messerschmitt passa
outre la consigne.
Les archives montrent
que plus de 600 262
avaient été reçus
par la Luftwaffe jusqu'en janvier,
mais un grand nombre
n'avait pu rejoindre leur unité
car ayant été détruit par
les chasseurs bombardiers alliés
sur les trains qui les transportait.
De même, une attention extrême
était portée à la protection
et au camouflage des 262 en service
pour les protéger
des chasseurs alliés en maraude
qui avaient fait
des jets des cibles prioritaires.
L'armement interne du 262
était le plus puissant
jamais installé sur
un chasseur allemand de toute la guerre.
Il comprenait quatre canons
de 30 mm montés dans le nez.
En plus,
24 roquettes R4M non guidées
pouvait être fixées
à des rails sous les ailes
et ajoutant
une puissance de feu considérable.
Dans le but d'équiper le 262
avec une puissance de feu
encore supérieure,
quelques-uns furent équipés en test
d'un canon de 50 mm
pour lutter contre les bombardiers.
Deux de ces armes
furent testées en janvier
et démontrèrent
que l'emport et l'installation de ce canon
étaient sans conséquences
sur le comportement du jet.
Basé à Achmer,
près de la frontière belge,
Nowotny était trop près
des bases aériennes alliées
pour employer le nouveau chasseur,
sans risque d'interception.
Les chasseurs alliés
découvrirent bien vite que le 262
était terriblement vulnérable
au décollage et à l'atterrissage,
et c'est pourquoi des avions
de protection Messerschmitt 109
et Focke-Wulf 190 furent mis
en place autour des aérodromes.
Galland était en visite à Achmer
pour discuter avec Nowotny,
lorsque le jeune commandant
et as de la chasse fut tué.
Le 8 décembre 1944,
il décolla avec son 262
pour attaquer les bombardiers US.
Son avion fut touché
et Nowotny tenta de regagner sa base,
mais il fut engagé par des Mustang
avec seulement un moteur encore en état.
Son 262 plongea et explosa au sol.
Enfant chéri de la propagande,
on lui fit des funérailles nationales.
Mort à l'âge de 24 ans avec
un score total de 258 victoires aériennes,
il est le pilote possédant
le cinquième plus haut score
de toute l'histoire de l'aviation.
Son unité fut dissoute
et reformée comme JG 7.
Le 262 fut engagé au combat
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
et c'est en mars 1945
qu'il connut son utilisation maximum.
Le 18, 37 Messerschmitt 262
engagèrent 1221 bombardiers
escortés par 632 chasseurs
qui avaient Berlin pour cible.
12 bombardiers et deux chasseurs
furent descendus par les jets
qui utilisaient la roquette R4M
pour la première fois.
Le dernier jour de mars,
les 262 détruisirent 14 bombardiers
et deux chasseurs sans aucune perte.
Dans le sud de l'Allemagne, la JG 44,
l'unité spéciale
commandée par Adolf Galland,
connut également son lot
de combats depuis Munich-Riem.
Alors que mille-deux-cents 262
avaient été livrés à la Luftwaffe
jusqu'en avril, moins de 200
étaient en unités de première ligne.
Dans cet extrait d'un film très rare,
on peut voir
un Messerschmitt 262 A-1a/U3
juste après son retour
d'une mission photographique.
Cet avion sert
au sein du Nahaufklärungsguppe 6,
précédemment connu
comme Einsatzkommando Braunegg,
basé dans le nord de l'Italie
en mars 1945.
Seulement une poignée
de cette version a été construite.
Le record d'avion opérationnel
a été de sept le 31 mars 1945.
Une fenêtre a été percée
dans le plancher du cockpit
pour que le pilote puisse voir
ce qu'il est en train de photographier.
Les canons de nez ont été enlevés
pour laisser la place
pour diverses caméras.
Quelques pilotes
ont quand même gardé un canon
aux côtés de leur caméra.
L'Arado 234 a été le premier
bombardier à réaction opérationnel.
Ses performances
dans des missions de reconnaissance
fin 44 début 45 avaient
démontré combien ses concepteurs
avaient raison de le baptiser "L'éclair".
Il était en effet capable de traverser
l'espace aérien allié en toute impunité.
Il fut construit pour satisfaire
une spécification de 1940
pour un avion
de reconnaissance très rapide.
Le prototype arriva en 1943
avec des ailes hautes
et un fuselage si étroit
qu'il empêchait l'installation
d'un train d'atterrissage conventionnel.
La variante présentée ici
est plus récente.
En l'absence
d'un train escamotable,
Arado reçut un chariot à trois roues
qui était fixé sous l'avion.
Mais ce n'était pas très pratique
de lever l'appareil
pour le poser sur son chariot.
Lors des premiers essais,
le 234 décolla avec le chariot fixé,
comme on l'observe sur ces images.
Pour le pilote qui devait
poser le 234 sur son chariot,
le challenge était difficile,
voire dangereux.
Le taux de descente de l'avion
et la suspension du chariot
faisaient rebondir l'ensemble
de façon incontrôlable pendant le roulage
et légèrement atténué au freinage.
Au bout de la piste,
le pilote perd le contrôle.
L'avion se couche
et s'abîme dans l'herbe.
L'avion d'essai vola de nouveau,
toujours avec le chariot, pour décoller.
Lorsque la vitesse de décollage
est atteinte, le pilote le largue.
À ce moment-là, un parachute se déploie
pour casser la vitesse du chariot
et l'empêcher de rebondir.
Les décollages avec chariot
furent effectués également
avec deux fusées Walter
afin d'augmenter la puissance.
Elles brûlaient pendant 30 secondes
et permettaient au 234
d'effectuer une montée initiale
plus rapide
et d'éviter toute collision
avec son chariot.
Une fois en l'air,
le 234 démontre sa vitesse
qui le rend très difficile
à intercepter par les chasseurs alliés.
Si on ne pouvait douter
des incroyables performances du 234,
le fait d'utiliser
un ski sous le fuselage
et deux petits patins
sous chaque réacteur pour l'atterrissage,
limitait sévèrement
son utilisation opérationnelle.
On finit par accepter le fait
que le 234 devait être repensé
afin de recevoir
un train d'atterrissage conventionnel.
Le modèle V huit du 234 A
était équipé de quatre réacteurs Jumo
pour servir de banc d'essai
à la version quadrimoteur 234 C.
Il devait disposer
du même fuselage que le B,
mais avec deux réacteurs de plus.
Le huitième prototype du 234
fut le premier à être produit
avec les spécifications de la version B.
Il fut conçu avec un fuselage
sensiblement plus large,
avec un train d'atterrissage solide
mais assez étroit.
Il effectua son premier vol
le 10 mars 1944.
Le 234 B devint
la première version opérationnelle
livrée au Sonderkommando Götz,
en septembre 1944.
Les avions de cette unité
furent utilisés
au-dessus du sud de l'Angleterre.
Dans le même temps,
deux 234 A encore équipés de skis,
avaient justifié leurs capacités
de reconnaissance
en survolant les plages du débarquement
de Normandie sans être interceptés.
La version de bombardement
effectue ses premières missions
avec le KG 76
pendant l'offensive des Ardennes
et le raid contre le pont de Remagen,
au tout début de 1945.
La plupart des 274 avions construits
furent des modèles B.
Les Messerschmitt 262 et les Arado 234,
quelles qu'en soient les versions,
furent les plus remarquables appareils
à entrer en service
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Quand les Alliés s'emparèrent
des bureaux d'études
des constructeurs aéronautiques allemands,
ils y découvrirent énormément
de projets de jets et de nombreuses idées
qui trouvèrent leur application
dans les premiers avions d'après-guerre.
La relative impuissance
de la force de bombardement
de la Luftwaffe sur le front ouest,
impliquée dans des raids
contre les îles Britanniques depuis 1942,
rendit impérative pour Hitler
l'idée d'une bombe volante.
Il trouva dans le Fieseler fi-103
son arme de la revanche
qui pouvait être utilisée en représailles
des raids dévastateurs
menés par la RAF
contre les villes allemandes.
Propulsé par un pulsoréacteur Argus
développant 350 kilos,
le V1 emportait
une charge explosive de 850 kilos
et suffisamment de carburant
pour voler pendant 1 heure,
à la vitesse de 640 km/h,
à l'altitude de 4 000 pieds.
Après les essais à Peenemünde
de près de la mer Baltique,
le V1 entra en service en 1943.
Le missile partait depuis
une longue rampe montante,
propulsé par un lanceur qui utilisait
le même carburant
que le Messerschmitt 163.
Les opérations devaient
commencer en décembre 1943,
mais ce n'est que le 13 juin 1944,
et une semaine après
le débarquement de Normandie,
que le premier V1 fut lancé depuis
le Pas de Calais vers Londres.
Cette offensive de bombardements
s'acheva le 5 septembre.
Le premier missile à atteindre
les environs de Londres
s'écrasa dans un terrain vague.
Face à l'ampleur de ces bombardements,
les Anglais tentèrent de les contrer
en massant de grandes quantités
de batteries anti-aériennes
le long des lignes d'approche des V1.
Des détachements de canons antiaériens
de 3,7 inches,
épaulés par des Bofors de 40 mm
plus légers,
utilisaient de grandes quantités
de munitions
dans leurs tentatives pour abattre les V1.
Bien qu'obtenant parfois quelques succès,
le nombre de coups au but augmenta
seulement lorsque les radars permirent
un contrôle de tir plus précis.
Pour donner une idée de l'intensité
des tirs de V1, du 15 au 30 juin,
pas moins de 2442 V1 furent lancés
contre Londres.
Les accidents de vol
et la DCA en détruisirent un tiers
au-dessus de la Manche.
Un autre tiers s'écrasa ou fut descendu
au-dessus du sud de l'Angleterre.
Le dernier tiers,
soit environ 800 missiles,
touchèrent leur cible dans
et autour de Londres.
Pour les habitants du sud
de l'Angleterre et de Londres,
l'arrivée des V1 était signalée
par le ronflement grandissant
du pulsoréacteur Argus.
Les Anglais finirent d'ailleurs
par baptiser le V1 Buzz Bomber.
L'impact psychologique
de cette arme était renforcé
par son comportement aléatoire.
Le V1 ne touchait le sol
qu'à épuisement de son carburant,
celui-ci étant signalé par un silence
soudain juste avant l'impact
suivi d'une énorme explosion.
Bien que la population de Londres
eût montré le même stoïcisme
que pendant le Blitz de 1940-41,
le V1 fit 2441 tués et 7107 blessés,
pendant une campagne où l'on dénombra
en moyenne 53 missiles lancés chaque jour
contre la capitale britannique.
Les services de renseignement britanniques
influencèrent le ciblage des V1
en donnant aux Allemands des informations
erronées sur les dommages subis.
Le chasseur à réaction Gloster F.1
faisait partie
des moyens anti-V1 de la RAF.
Les chasseurs à moteur à pistons,
employés pour chasser le V1,
étaient le redoutable Hawker Tempest
et le Spitfire Mark 14.
Ils furent responsables
de la destruction de plus de 300 V1.
En raison du rayon d'action limité du V1,
les sites de lancement étaient
tous situés dans le Pas de Calais.
Les premières rampes fixes furent
bombardées et détruites par les Alliés
bien avant le jour J.
Avec la libération
de cette région par les Anglais
et les Canadiens en septembre,
les bombardements des V1 cessèrent.
Pourtant, le calvaire de Londres
n'était pas fini,
car les Allemands se préparaient
à employer une nouvelle arme.
Bien que la fusée A4, plus connue
sous sa désignation V2,
ait été davantage un projet
de l'armée allemande que de la Luftwaffe,
elle mérite sa place dans la catégorie
des armes aériennes allemandes
les plus modernes utilisées
pendant la guerre.
Considérée comme le début
de la conquête de l'espace
et le résultat du plus important et du
plus coûteux programme militaire nazi,
elle est véritablement une arme ultime
représentative de l'avancée technologique
de l'Allemagne pendant la guerre.
Cependant, Albert Speer,
ancien ministre de la production
d'armement du Troisième Reich,
lorsqu'il revint
sur les événements passés
dans le silence de sa cellule
de la prison de Spandau,
où il purgeait sa peine de 20 ans
pour crimes de guerre,
admit qu'en dépit du caractère
brillant du programme A4,
ce fut d'un point de vue militaire
et industriel,
un véritable gaspillage
des ressources allemandes.
Avec des origines
remontant à l'avant guerre,
le développement d'une fusée
à long rayon d'action
occupa des milliers
de scientifiques et de militaires
au sein du centre d'essais secret
de Peenemünde, pendant des années.
La création d'une arme
si révolutionnaire fut longue.
Les premiers prototypes
de la A4 connurent bien des déboires,
car il fallut surmonter
de nombreuses difficultés
afin de maîtriser
ces technologies avancées.
Le premier lancement réussi
d'une fusée A4 eut lieu
à partir du pas de tir 7 de Peenemünde,
le 3 octobre 1942.
La fusée s'éleva vers le ciel en passant
le mur du son pendant son ascension
et alla s'abîmer
en mer à 200 km au large.
L'avancement du développement continua
et les essais permirent
de fiabiliser la fusée.
Hitler, très sceptique au départ,
commença à entrevoir
le potentiel opérationnel
de cette fusée à longue portée.
En juillet 1943,
avec la A4, alors considérée comme
l'une des armes de la revanche
avec laquelle il serait possible
de frapper l'Angleterre,
Hitler exigea de l'industrie allemande
qu'elle se lance dans l'audacieux pari
de produire pas moins
de 900 de ces fusées par mois.
L'emploi de matériaux précieux,
d'électronique,
d'une ingénierie compétente
et d'une main d'œuvre massive
consacrée à ce projet,
ponctionna les ressources
de l'économie de guerre allemande.
Alors qu'à cette époque,
il était déjà devenu difficile
de mettre en service des armes
plus conventionnelles
et pourtant indispensables.
L'importance du projet attira l'attention
des SS, et ce fut sous leur autorité,
qu'une importante usine souterraine
fut construite par des déportés
dans les montagnes de Nordhausen,
en Allemagne,
afin de produire en masse le V2.
La plupart des composants
les plus sophistiqués de la fusée,
comme les gyroscopes,
les systèmes de contrôle,
les réservoirs de carburant
et les éléments du système de guidage,
furent confiés à des sous-traitants
possédant les compétences nécessaires.
Ils étaient ensuite acheminés
pour l'assemblage final.
L'intégration de tant d'éléments
exigeait un processus continu d'essais
et de contrôles pour s'assurer
que la fusée quittait l'usine,
prête à être lancée.
Le premier tir opérationnel
d'une fusée V2 eut lieu dans l'après-midi
du 8 septembre 1944.
Elle s'abattit sur Chiswick,
dans la banlieue ouest de Londres.
L'explosion de la tonne d'explosif
de la charge de la fusée
fit trois morts et 17 blessés.
La fusée avait été lancée
depuis La Haye en Hollande.
Utilisant un système
de lancement mobile,
il était difficile aux alliés
de les attaquer.
Une fois en l'air,
la fusée était invulnérable.
Dans les sept mois qui suivirent,
les Allemands lancèrent 1054 fusées
contre Londres,
tuant ainsi 2700 personnes.
Les alliés ne gaspillèrent pas leur temps
à tenter de contrer ces fusées
et contrairement à ce qu'espérait Hitler,
elles n'eurent aucun impact
sur le déroulement de la guerre.
Voici comment
cette arme était déployée et lancée.
Tout commence avec un V2
en cours d'assemblage final.
Les techniciens travaillant
sur l'arrière du missile
utilisent des équipements de test
pour s'assurer de l'état du moteur-fusée
avant de finaliser le montage.
Les essais à ce stade
de l'assemblage sont vitaux,
car une fois le fuselage refermé
sur la fusée,
il est impossible à l'équipe de lancement
d'y accéder en cas de problème.
Un FAUN 4 et deux zugmaschinen
remorquent le réservoir
de carburant d'oxygène liquide.
Un autre camion tracte
un générateur mobile.
Le camion FAUN
tractant le réservoir LOX
est facilement reconnaissable
grâce aux émanations
d'oxygène s'échappant
par l'arrière du gros réservoir.
Ce petit convoi traverse un village
sur son chemin vers le site de lancement.
Le V2 est volumineux.
Il était très vulnérable lors
des déplacements ferroviaires
entre le centre d'assemblage et le front.
Le temps que les Allemands commencent
à lancer les V2 à partir de La Haye,
les Alliés étaient déjà en Europe,
et avançaient à travers la Belgique
vers la Hollande.
Le réseau entier de routes
et de voies ferrées
au nord de l'Allemagne et les Pays-Bas,
toujours utilisés par la Wehrmacht,
étaient sous surveillance constante
et attaqués par
les chasseurs bombardiers alliés.
C'est pour cette raison que beaucoup,
si ce n'est tous les V2 envoyés
vers le front, étaient camouflés.
Ceux vus avec de grandes marques noires
et blanches sont des fusées expérimentales
et ce film a été tourné
à des fins d'instruction.
Voici le processus précis
des équipes de lancement de V2
pour la préparation de la fusée
et son arrivée par rail
vers son point de lancement,
caractéristique
de tous les lancements de V2
en direction de Londres
et plus tard d'Anvers.
Avec une grue mobile,
la fusée est déchargée et installée
sur une remorque spécialement conçue.
On note l'absence de la charge explosive
qui est transportée évidemment à part.
Arrivée sur le site de lancement,
à bonne distance de la voie ferrée,
les armuriers enlèvent
la protection du nez du V2
et préparent
l'installation de la charge.
Elle se trouve dans son propre conteneur
qui est installé en haut de la fusée,
grâce à une chaîne et un palan.
On prend bien soin d'aligner
la charge utile sur son emplacement,
avant de la fixer solidement.
Son poids est de 975 kilos.
Ailleurs, d'autres membres
de l'équipe montent des tréteaux.
Ce sont des outils standards,
qui sont employés généralement
pour la maintenance des panzers,
et utilisés pour soulever les tourelles
des chars lourds Tigre.
Ils peuvent supporter 15 tonnes.
La charge militaire enfin à sa place,
le FAUN soulève le V2.
Un second camion FAUN se range
aux côtés du premier.
Il tire le chariot spécial utilisé
pour transporter le V2 assemblé
vers son site de lancement,
et une fois sur place,
le lève pour être placé
sur la plateforme de lancement.
La grue mobile est utilisée
pour déplacer le V2
depuis son wagon vers sa remorque.
La lenteur du déplacement de la fusée
d'une remorque à l'autre
est une indication de la délicatesse
utilisée par les équipes
qui manipulent le missile.
Il est important d'éviter
le moindre dégât.
De grandes précautions sont prises
par l'équipe
pour verrouiller le V2 sur son berceau.
La charge installée,
mais sans carburant à bord,
tout est organisé
afin d'éviter un accident.
La fusée est sécurisée
sur la structure de sa remorque.
La fusée est maintenant conduite
vers le site de lancement.
Près de la voie ferrée,
un autre détachement, chargé de remplir
le carburant de la fusée,
arrive pour connecter la pompe
qui permet le transfert
de l'oxygène liquide
depuis le wagon citerne
vers le réservoir mobile,
fixé sur un camion et qui doit rejoindre
le site de lancement.
Lorsque tous les tuyaux sont connectés,
les valves sont ouvertes
et le transfert de l'oxygène liquide
commence.
La température très basse du liquide
est repérable avec ses tuyaux blanchis
et les vapeurs qui s'en échappent.
Sur le site de lancement, un autre FAUN
tracte le socle de lancement.
Les équipes commencent
à préparer le lanceur.
À chaque coin
de la plateforme de lancement
se trouve
un support télescopique.
Ils sont descendus et mis en position
en prévision de l'arrivée
et de l'installation de la fusée.
Il semble que cette procédure
soit facilitée par un sol solide,
mais en fait, la mobilité du lanceur de V2
s'accommodait de n'importe quel espace,
même sommairement aménagé
au milieu d'une forêt.
Pour empêcher la plateforme de lancement
de s'enfoncer dans un sol meuble,
on place simplement sur le sol
des traverses de chemin de fer,
ou des plaques métalliques sur lesquelles
vont reposer les quatre pieds du lanceur.
Ce sont des méthodes comme celles-ci
qui ont été utilisées
pour les lanceurs de La Haye.
Avant de lancer la fusée, des techniciens
placent un berceau spécial sur le nez.
Il permet d'effectuer les derniers
ajustements de la charge militaire,
juste avant le lancement.
Le Meillerwagen est tracté vers
la plateforme de lancement par le FAUN.
Il est garé juste derrière.
Les câbles relient le Meillerwagen
et la plateforme.
On retourne le chariot pour que la base
de la fusée soit face à la plateforme.
Le FAUN est déconnecté
et laisse les techniciens
placer le chariot manuellement
pour que le V2 arrive exactement
dans la bonne position pour être levé.
Pour cela, on utilise
le système hydraulique du chariot.
C'est une manœuvre assez lente
mais vitale, car les quatre pieds du V2
doivent être précisément
positionnés sur la plateforme.
Très lentement,
la bombe volante V2 se soulève
et atteint sa position verticale,
avec beaucoup de précaution.
Quand le responsable est certain
que tout est OK,
la fusée est déconnectée de tous
les systèmes de levage
et se tient debout
seule sur son support.
À ce moment, le responsable
donne l'ordre par radio
au responsable du véhicule de carburant,
d'arriver pour la phase suivante
du cycle de lancement,
qui n'est pas la moins dangereuse.
Les chariots sont reculés à la main
et éloignés de la fusée.
On procède
à un examen rigoureux de la fusée,
afin de s'assurer
que tout est au point.
Des ingénieurs civils responsables
du lancement utilisent leur théodolite
pour s'assurer que le missile
est bien aligné à la verticale,
car une très légère déviation
peut affecter la trajectoire de la fusée,
et donc son efficacité.
Un autre technicien arme les explosifs.
Bien qu'installée depuis un moment,
cette procédure n'était pas initiée
à l'avance.
En bas, les générateurs mobiles
sont amenés
pour fournir l'énergie au système interne,
dont les pompes d'alimentation,
qui facilitent le processus
de remplissage du carburant.
Les tuyaux sont déjà connectés.
Les réserves d'oxygène liquide du V2
ont une capacité de 5,5 tonnes
et le mélange comporte également
plus de quatre tonnes d'alcool
et 180 kilos de peroxyde d'hydrogène
afin de fournir les 24 tonnes
de poussée nécessaire
au décollage de la fusée.
Après l'oxygène liquide, le dernier
ingrédient important
est le permanganate de sodium,
qui est ajouté dans le réservoir
le plus bas de la fusée.
L'étape suivante consiste à installer
les systèmes d'allumage.
Alors que les derniers ajustements
sont faits à la base du missile,
en particulier le réglage
du système de guidage,
tous les véhicules
et le personnel se mettent à l'abri.
Les systèmes d'allumage sont installés
dans le venturi et connectés.
Le V2 est prêt pour le lancement.
Le lancement est effectué depuis
une variante blindée
du Half-track de huit tonnes.
Bien que d'une valeur militaire
discutable,
le V2 est indubitablement
une réussite technique remarquable.
La définition la plus juste
de la plus puissante
de toutes les armes allemandes
a été donnée par Walter Dornberger
à Wernher von Braun, le concepteur du V2,
le jour de son premier lancement réussi.
"Tu réalises ce que
nous avons fait aujourd'hui ?"
"Nous avons lancé
le premier vaisseau spatial."